[Music]
hello and welcome back to chess every
explained my name is caleb done b and
today i am going to be taking you
through one of the most famous chess
matches to be played throughout history
of course tonight i am talking about the
Kasparov Karpov match from 1985 where
Kasparov dethroned Anatoly Karpov to
take his world championship title now
the reason I wanted to focus on a match
like this is because these World
Championship matches really at any point
throughout the past like 3040 years this
is where players like Kasparov like
Karpov and nowadays like Magnus Carlsen
like Fabiana karamaneh and like I don't
know perhaps yonder poni she maxine
mashaallah grabbed this year still
remains to be seen but this is where
these best of the best players take
months off from their standard careers
you know they take breaks from these
other huge tournaments and what they do
is they go somewhere warm and sunny and
they take you know five to ten of their
closest friends with them and their
closest friends sent spend all of their
days in this nice and sunny weather
locked in a basement looking at computer
screens trying their hardest to prepare
openings so there is one opening line in
particular that went really well for
Karpov in this match and I wanted to
kind of go game by game each time this
opening line was played and see how each
players were reacting to each other what
interesting novelties they kind of came
up with against each other and how they
ended up favor and Kass brought in the
end so why don't we just jump right into
it the line I want to talk about
actually first appeared in Game one of
the match Garry Kasparov with the white
pieces in game one came out with d4
Anatoly responded Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight
c3 Bishop b4 and of course this is the
nimzo-indian
fence now there are a lot of different
moves that white can play here f3 it's
personal favorite of mine as many of you
may know but Gary's fourth move in this
game was actually the first time it
appeared on the board between Kasparov
and Karpov of course they had played
this position many many times but this
was the first time I believe that Gary
played the move Knight f3 so this was a
bit of a shocker to Anatoly Karpov and
this is what you can expect to see and a
lot of these World Championship matches
these players want to play something
that their opponents aren't ready for
and so they'll often take this
opportunity at the highest level at the
most important match of their lives to
try something they have not seen on the
board yet so Knight f3 and now Knight f3
is interesting it's not really seen as
the most critical line against the
nimzo-indian these days and the reason
for that is it's it's just not very not
very testing right black is threatening
to take on c3 and fracture the white
pawn structure also going for some
squares in the middle like II for Knight
f3 removes the option lepre moving this
pawn to f3 or even to f4 it also removes
the option of bringing this Knight to e2
to help support this knight on c3 so
Knight f3 while it's a perfectly fine
move and in fact it is a move that aims
for some really important central
squares like a5 it's not really seen as
the most threatening that being said
though you know the question is now on
anatoly karpov and you know you can
spend hours and hours and hours getting
ready for a match but you can't prepare
every line in the game of chess there's
just simply too many and this is one of
those ones or perhaps Karpov thought
that he could rely more on his common
sense and intuition and chess ability
rather than opening prep and we'll see
did quite work out for him here
so Karpov chose c5 and this is one of
the most common lines in fact I think it
is the most common line against Knight
f3 the point is you immediately strike
back in the center now Kasparov chooses
the move g3 just preparing to fee and
keto this Bishop and get on this nice
open diagonal which has actually been
weakened by the move c5 now this pawn is
on c5 can no longer step to c6 and this
just feels a little bit more loose now
by far the most popular move here is C
takes d4 C takes d4 is is really what
the players play these days and there
are games here you know between magnus
carlsen and Fabi Kara Juana Wesley so
has played this with Blackbaud Kramnik
has played this with black Vichy and
non-display this with black but Karpov
shows the much less common Knight e4 and
already he is walking a dangerous
tightrope here Knight e4 is a move that
you play when you are absolutely
prepared for a line and I think Karpov
really didn't do the homework on this
one which is why it's so interesting to
see how Gary won this game so after
Knight e4 there are a few moves that
have been played Queen c2 is one even
Bishop d2 is one just breaking the pin
like this
Gary plays this move though Queen to d3
and now we get a really interesting
position here where this Knight is is
not going to remain on the e4 square you
don't really want to play something like
f5 it just feels a little bit too
weakening d5 in fact is is also a little
bit premature here you're just not quite
ready to play these breaks in the center
if d5 probably even just the simple
Bishop g2 and without this knight on f6
d5 is seriously going to be a weak point
so in the game Queen a5 was was Karpov
choice and this is still an okay move us
plenty of top players that actually
played this position but now after Queen
takes e4 we see the move Bishop takes c3
with check and the point for white is
not to recapture this Bishop when after
Queen takes you're going to lose a rook
on a1 but rather just to play the move
Bishop d2 so white captures the knight
on e4 black captures a knight on D to
the play continues pretty naturally here
Bishop takes d2 is more or less forced
now Knight takes D - and this is where
perhaps Anatoli started to go a bit
now obviously I didn't see this much
happen life but from what I've read
about the match
Karpov spent an enormous amount of time
on these first few moves and this move
in particular is probably the first time
when he thought he could play something
that looks fairly natural but in reality
it is a little bit less comfortable then
then you would want so by far the main
move here is knight c6 and this is a
position that was actually played as
recently as 2015 by time timur raja
baath of course raja baath also one of
the world's best and that game continued
d takes e5 Queen c5 Bishop to b5 and
after a few more moves the Queen's got
traded b takes e4 takes takes takes with
so many pieces liquidated white can
target this weakness on c6 perhaps why
it's going to have a pretty nice night
here with squares like e5 and e6 and a5
to even look at but this turned out to
be nothing and a simple drop between
fabok Arowana
and raja baath there but instead of
knight c6
Karpov plays this slightly weird-looking
move Queen b6 and this is one of those
moves where like perhaps you've you've
seen it once you know it should be fine
for black but if you really haven't done
the homework here then you you could get
a little bit stuck and the fact that's
what happens here D takes e5 is the
natural response from Kasparov of course
this poem is under a lot of pressure now
rather than take back on c5 this would
be a pretty bad position where white is
just up in development and up a little
bit in the central space
Karpov goes for Queen takes B to Ric b1
is the only move and now this is really
the move where Kasparov could solidify
his advantage Karpov needed to play the
move Queen a3 so you keep things a bit
more level Queen a3 is frankly just a
better square looking at this pawn on c5
now the move Queen a 2 isn't really what
black is interested in doing this Queen
is going to be pretty far out of play
and
move between d4 is going to come on the
board and the kingside is going to come
under some fire but rather queen a3 is
the way to get the Queen back into play
with the key point being you are
attacking this pawn on c5 now Queen d4
is the most common move here but black
simply castles and like I said this
pressure here is going to be enough to
get the Queen in if white gets a little
bit funny and try something like rook b3
we can always step back to a5 and come
back this way
moves like Knight a6 are going to come
next to really ensure that we are
getting this pawn back but rather than
Queen a3 Karpov chose the move Queen c3
here and now garry kasparov I believe
simply has a very nice advantage the
move Queen d3 it's how he solidifies
that advantage note these pawns were
doubled and isolated but after Queen d3
black really doesn't want to play move
like Queen a5 or queen bee 5 for various
reasons one of which being for example
Queen e5 the move Queen d6 really makes
things awkward for black and you're
going to have to trade these Queens
anyways so Queen takes d3 is the best
move eat akes d3 now and the problem for
black is that it's not so simple anymore
to regain this pawn on c5 now this is an
extra this isn't an extra pawn for white
material is in fact even in this
position but if you just look at the
activity of the white pieces you can
really see that's if blacks not up a
pawn here black is going to be in quite
a bit of danger personally I think if in
this position you take this pawn off the
board
maybe black can claim some kind of
equality but I honestly doubt it I think
I would still prefer white without the
c5 pawn on the board
that's just how active the pieces are
and gary won this opening battle rather
convincingly I will play through the
rest of this game to let you see how
Gary ended up converting the move d4 of
course is the point for white here
solidifying this pawn here on c5 and
perhaps you guys at home can kind of
guess what the the best move in my
opinion is it it's not a pretty move
it's not a move you enjoy making but I
think it's a move that
to be made here so I'll let the chat go
ahead and and try and figure out what
what move ended up being played in this
position and what move I think should
have been played
yes also yeah hello to everyone in the
chat I know that was a long bit of just
me talking but I hope you guys enjoyed
some of the background on this match
hello to arch hello
Abhishek who is claiming I'm a genius
hard to disagree just kidding just
kidding I do a lot of prep sooo Bakura
says the move h5 that's a little bit
beside the point
rook b8 is the move that was played in
the game repeat isn't a bad move at all
but yet the the chat is saying it now
the move I would have liked to see is
actually this move e5 I think this is
something that Karpov definitely should
have considered rook b8 and b6 are still
going to have to come at some point in
the game so it makes a little bit of
sense to start with those as well but I
like playing a5 as soon as I can the
reason being this Knight really does
need to get back into the game and if
we're not taking on c5 this Knights just
going to be awful and with e5 I don't
think white would even capture on e5
white is likely still a fair bit better
here but I think this is being a little
bit too kind to Karpov in fact probably
just the move Bishop g2 would come and
then maybe eventually we do have to take
this actually but you could probably
even consider just leaving it there and
going for some really serious counter
play immediately but yeah I like the
move e5 the point being we need to get
this knight back into the game 'if I've
looks entirely unnatural but it's it's
kind of what you have to do at this
point
rook b8 played in the game though like I
said also a move that was going to be
required from Karpov at some point
Bishop g2 now like I said just
pressuring on this long diagonal note no
C pawn not playing c6 here never playing
c6 here part of the downside of playing
c5 and once again I think the move e5 is
called for black chose King e 7 instead
going for a different way to get the
knight back into the game now King e2
and rook d8 from
Karp of 94 though and this is is really
showing that things have have gone quite
poorly the move b6 is car pops try you
really do have to develop these pieces
somehow but now after 96 this Bishop
can't even come to b7 and this is just
the saddest chess position I've ever
seen in my life
Knight c7 played in the game but
honestly it's difficult to argue that
the knight on c7 is an improvement from
the knight on a 6 the idea is to come to
d8 and kick this night out of d6 but
it's all just a fair bit too slow
rook before is natural from Kasparov
getting ready to double and just win on
the Queen side 98 does come on the board
Knight takes the 8th King takes e8 and
rook b12 follow this Bishop finally
comes to an active square but it's a
little bit too little too late King III
on pins the move d5 is what Karpov tried
but this is really the losing move I
think Karpov is already losing in this
position maybe you can try a bit harder
with just sitting honestly it's it's
really difficult to come up with a move
for for black here you're just losing
this the b6 pawn and with the b61 you're
losing the game like maybe you play King
g7 or something but you can even just
capture here and at the end of the day
eight pawns a pawns run I think I didn't
even play this the most accurately for
white but this would already be a really
great position I think here even the
move c5 is a little bit more convincing
and you just keep the position with
threats of rook F for to to come okay
what's happening oh no things are
breaking I better refresh ok I've
refreshed things seem to be going a bit
better my board turned black that was
terrifying
all right now all my side lines are
messed up though oh boy oh boy
alright here I found it I found it ok
skip to the end fun stuff
ok so like I said d5 is what cart pops
right but now after C takes D 6 this is
just tactically totally busted if you
end up taking this guy back the move C 5
is just destroying the black position so
rook see it instead hit c4 and now takes
but this is just totally dead lost white
is up a clean pawn on this Queen side
and the rooks are too active the pawns
to mobile and this game ended up going
in cast brows favor
I played through the end pretty quickly
there but this isn't openings classes so
let's try to stay with the openings okay
moving on to game number 2 in the
lecture game number 7 in the world
championship match this is actually the
first time that this opening line was
repeated I believe in the interim
Karpov played a couple Queens gambit
declined games and Kasparov tried his
hand at 1.e4 and was thoroughly trounced
so back to d4 it is for Kasparov and now
we end up in this nimza line again
Knight f3 and if you recall from game
one game one didn't go very well for
Karpov so you can expect Karpov to come
back to this game feeling a little bit
more prepared with some more interesting
ideas to counter this opening and car
pops choice was another slightly more
uncommon move in the first game of
course he played c5 which leads to some
very interesting positions but here
Karpov simply castles Kasparov chooses
to play at Bishop c5 highlighting the
fact that that's with this bishop on b4
it's a slightly more difficult to break
this pin on the
tonight and now the move d6 from Karpov
is also pretty non-standard and honestly
I don't love this opening choice from
Karpov at all this is kind of okay so
with d6 what Karpov is saying is he's
not going to play these moves like c5
he's not going to directly challenge the
white center and when you do that even
if your position is objectively fine you
end up in these kinds of positions where
you simply have less space and you're
working very very hard to to defend it
so I really didn't like this this
opening trace from Karpov even though
this game did end up not going totally
in Gary's favor the move III now from
White Knight bd7
from black Queen c2 from white b6 is the
natural continuation from black and as I
said you see that that black is really
playing a bit more cagey leaving all his
pieces on these these first three ranks
of course aside from this Bishop and not
playing any pawn moves on the v rank
here and like I said while doing this
you're posing no threat to the white
center and by posing no threat to the
white center white more-or-less has a
free hand to develop any way that he
sees fit the move Bishop d3 comes on the
board and Karpov plays Bishop takes c3
unprovoked which is not the most
standard but not not the worst idea here
either
Karpov rather than Queen takes c3
actually chooses the move B takes c3 and
this is an interesting recapture by
Kasparov here the point is he wants to
open the B file and get a little bit of
pressure on this side of the board the B
file is actually going to be
particularly relevant in this game
because that is where the bishop wants
to make its home so with a bishop on b7
black is either going to have to commit
a piece to defending this bishop or he's
going to have to worry about threats of
c5 when the pin on the B file is going
to make his position a little bit
awkward so B takes c3 it also has the
added benefit of adding a bit of support
to this d4 pawn giving this efore pawn a
bit more mobility with this pawn being
backed up
now age six comes on the board bishop
age for Bishop b7 and then a very
interesting move from garry kasparov he
basically baits Karpov into going for
some some slightly more crazy positions
it would be perfectly fine here for
white to simply castle it'd be fine here
for white to play a move like 'if or
even but Kasparov chooses the move
Knight d2 now I don't know how good you
guys are at chess but my level of chess
is that wait a second I know how to
count zero defenders on this pawn one
attacker that's a free pawn got to take
those guys turns out in this case that
way of thinking about chess might
actually be correct here as young
Gustafson says a pawn is a pawn so I
think Bishop takes g2 it is actually
just going to be really really nice for
black here white does get this open G
file and a lot of pressure against the
king side after move like f4 but it's
already the type of position where it's
like black has less space I don't know
why Karpov went for this position it's
really uncomfortable
in positions like this where you have
less space and you feel like you're just
kind of sitting back and waiting for
your opponent to find a way to break
through it's really really nice to have
something in return for that you know
something you can hold on to and say
well you know my opponent might have all
the plants but look at me I've got a
jeep on he doesn't have a cheap on and I
have a jeep on and this is something
that a lot of the top players today now
actually do when they find themselves
you know in a slightly positionally
worse circumstance they like to have
something to play for so that's when
you'll see them take slightly bigger
risks going for for more materialistic
ideas saying you know if I if I can't
have a good position at least I'll have
a material edge and then I have
something to play for so I really would
have liked Bishop takes g2 here by a
Karpov instead though the move g5 breaks
the pin on this night and after Bishop
g3 if you're going to take on g2 you
should have done it before playing g5 so
that idea has kind of sailed in the move
Knight h5
was anatoly's idea here now Kasparov
plays a slightly strange move queen d1
challenging this Knight forcing it to
make a decision immediately either black
is ready to take on g3 and open up the H
file or he's not in this case he was not
in play tonight g7 unfortunately for
Anatoly I think this was one step too
far the move Knight g7 it is really just
kind of asking for it here I mean you
play h6 you play g5 you play Knight h5
if you play all of these moves only to
play the move Knight g7 something is is
a bit fishy here
Knight h5 was clearly with the intent of
taking this Bishop on g3 and I think he
just kind of kind of wussed out for lack
of a better term you know it's easy to
be afraid of this this h-file moves like
Queen h5 look very threatening
but after rook aid shape this this pawn
is defended and it's not so easy at all
for a white breakthrough of course
that's easy for me to sit here and say
in the year 2020 having analyzed this
game having had this game analyzed you
know you know countless times before me
and you know I'm not sitting across the
table from Gary Kasparov but the move
Knight g7 really just feels like like
it's asking for it here and so I'll ask
you guys at home to find the move for
white that continues the attack will
rather kind of begins the attack taking
advantage of blacks slightly soft last
move
yes gift me the pun that one is not a
young Gustafson quote but rather a yeah
source erawan quote gift me the pawn
alright I'm not going to wait the full
duration for the chat delay to catch up
I assume most of you guys have it here
the move is H for black has weakened the
structure rather needlessly and then
rather than following through on his
idea he is allowing white to simply open
up this age file more favorably I think
G 7 may be my least favorite square for
a night honestly because somehow it's
right in front of the king but defends
none of the relevant squares
it doesn't defend any of these squares
it's it's just not a good square for a
knight f5 is anatoly's reply to h4 no
need to stop now for Kasparov he
continues through takes in takes and now
he has an open H file to play with
against this black King White's next
loop is also fairly natural note that I
said one of the big benefits of taking
back on c3 with the pawn is yes it opens
up this B file for some potential play
but it also supports this d4 pawn which
makes this a pawn and gain of mobility
and that's why we see Kasparov play the
move f3 here he's looking at potentially
four ideas later on but for the moment
he's giving his Bishop a nice score on
f2 to drop back he's also taking away
any approaching squares that this night
would be aiming for so f3 Queenie 7 by
Karpov and now Queen b3 by Kasparov like
I said pressure on the B file and now
black is forced 20 move king f7 he
simply doesn't have enough space for his
pieces and he needs to get this King out
of the way so that he can challenge
these rooks on the on the H file here
Kasparov naturally castles Queen side
note that because you know black really
hasn't challenged the center at all he's
more than happy to castle on this side
of the board because black is so far
away from opening any of these files
from from getting at this King Ric h8
now is begging force
trades and now this is where Kasparov
kind of starts to - let it slip just a
little bit I think in this position
after some analysis I do believe the
best plan is to play for an e-form move
I think if white can achieve the movie
for start threatening things like a
takes f5 or if what black responds with
an f4 moves like g3 and this is how
white can really open things up in front
of this black king in the game however
[Music]
Kasparov went for an immediate c5 just
show you an example line though for
example a bishop f2 stepping out of the
way of f4 if black plays some move like
a 5 for example it can continue now
immediately with a move like a 4 or you
can continue prepping it with something
like Queen c2 and eventually you know
black is going to try to find counter
play but the movie 4 is going to come
and there's just simply no good reply to
this if you play the move f4
like I said the move g3 is going to be
powerful the movie 5 in this case is
also just kind of dominating opening up
this diagonal entirely if you take here
well we'll simply take back with some
piece I think any piece is fine with the
pawn seems fairly natural what the open
a file week Jeep on threats of a 5 this
is really just gonna be devastating for
black in my opinion now I didn't play
the best moves for black here I just
kind of made some random pawn moves and
let white do what he was hoping to do
but the fact is it's it's really
difficult to play against this idea for
for black here you can't really stop be
for white just has too much firepower on
this square so I think that might have
been a better way to continue for
Kasparov instead though at the move c5
now after D takes e5 Knight c4 white is
still doing pretty well here but he's
kind of sacrificed this pawn for for no
good reason
now lacking this pawn on c3 the movie 4
is going to be a lot more difficult to
to actually pull off here and in fact
after the move f4 and Bishop f2 the move
Knight h5 comes on the board in the
movie 4 is starting to feel more and
more just kind of empty this night could
potentially return and now
with this pawn also missing from the c-4
square the d5 square is going to become
available to black if you ever dare push
this pawn to e5
so these C pawns they were important
Gary why did you give them away they did
really good stuff here and I think
that's where most of whites advantage
started to slip after a night at 5:00
Bishop c2 was Gary's choice another
slightly weird move F takes c3 Bishop
takes c3 and now the move Bishop d5 it's
black is it's more or less doing totally
fine now he's gotten this pieces into
the game the white Center has somehow
self-destructed and black is is doing
fine and this game did in fact end up in
a draw rather shortly Bishop takes f4
and now after rook takes h8 or at takes
h8 queen to g6 check King f8 White has
backed himself into a little bit of a
corner and Gary had to go for a
perpetual check here rook takes d5 is
the sacrifice to find it
II take c5 and they agreed to a draw
here the idea is simply queen of five
check when Queen see a check is enough
for the draw no way to escape
these checks for black so they agree to
a draw after a takes d5 but this being
an openings class I wanted to stress how
poorly this opening went for and totally
they really don't play chess like this
anymore at the top level you have to do
something you know you have to challenge
your opponent in some way because if you
just give them a free hand as Anatoly
did in this game more than likely
they're gonna be able to use it to get
an advantage as Gary did opening up this
h-file
and getting at that black King so lesson
from this game do something in the
opening okay don't just sit back and do
nothing always moving on to game 3 of
the lecture this is game 11 in the match
and this is actually one of the more
famous ones and this one an atonally
Anatoly did finally seem to figure out
the opening well wait a second no no
this isn't game 11 yet this is round 13
where's game 11 hold on here's game 11 I
found it sorry got a little bit out of
order there so let's take a look
d4 Knight f6
or v6 Knight c3 Bishop b4 Knight f3 once
again from Gary it's working for him why
not stick to it and now Anatoly goes for
this castling move again rather than the
immediate c5 but after Bishop g5 he
perhaps realized his foolishness but
it's playing d6
and you know doing nothing all game long
and then suffering so he chose c5 in
this case and once again this is back
into pretty normal territory this is
perfectly fine for black the move III is
Gary's reply here note that this is a
little bit different than the g3 we had
seen previously but the difference here
is we've already gotten this Bishop
outside the pawn chain so we're more
than happy to play the move III C takes
D for each takes d4 and now the move h6
feels a little bit early but it is
perfectly fine
Bishop h4 comes on the board and now
Anatoly goes for the move d5 with some
slightly more normal looking Queens pawn
positions you know you could get this
way you get this position from a variety
of different opening lines it's one of
those positions in Queens gambit
structures that just seems to always
kind of appear in some fashion of course
this is going to end up being an
isolated Queens pawn one of the most
common structures in all of chess rook
c1 was Gary's choice now the move d6 d4
perhaps comes a little bit early
allowing Gary to develop this Bishop
with tempo but Karpov is simply securing
the iqp structure a structure he
probably knows a little bit better than
the craziness we saw in these first two
games so Anatoly falling back on the
idea that if you just can get a chess
game he'll be able to to do all right
knight c6 to follow is perfectly natural
now castles Bishop e7 is a really nice
move from Karpov just because you played
Bishop before once this Bishop has kind
of outlived its usefulness here you
don't really need to kill it for no
reason the bishop is doing well on e7
here
so good move by Karpov now the move
rookie one comes on the board pretty
natural stuff from Mike putting the
rooks on the open files b6 now is
attempting to develop blacks last piece
the move a3 is a pretty common move in
these iqp structures it's simply really
important not to let this night get to
the d5 square via beef for sometimes it
gets there via e7 but it is slightly
more awkward for black and then the the
more natural Knight p45 Bishop e7 is the
natural follow up now Bishop g3 and it
is kind of gistic kind of just a chess
game at this point
rook c8 challenges these rooks Bishop a
to Bishop d6 offers a trade and now with
d5 white is more or less saying okay
good game of chess I'll play d5 well
simplify some stuff perhaps I will have
a slightly more activity for the
immediate future I'm going to try to
make something of it there but if I
can't you know a good game will will
agree to a draw Knight takes d5 and
Knight takes d5 Bishop takes g3 it
shakes g3 and now he takes d5 Bishop
takes d5 and this is one of those
positions where if white can prove
something in the next I don't know say
three four or five moves then white
might have a bit of an advantage but in
this case there's simply not enough left
on the board to be able to prove
anything and black is doing totally fine
here the move Queen f6 comes on the
board hitting the b2 pawn queen a4 is
Gary's reply countering with an attack
on the a7 pawn and now after the move
rook FD 8 hitting this Bishop rook CD 1
was played and now the move rook d7 and
black is is I'm not going to lie to you
here just just totally dead equal at
this point well I got the rooks into
play there's a little bit of pressure on
c6 but it's so well defended that
nothing is really going to happen there
the a7 pawn is you know something
White's trying to attack but you can't
ever really get to it because now this
pawn has even defended in addition to
that b2 is always hanging in reply and
this is just a dead equal position so
what does Gary do in the dead
equal position well of course he tries
to swindle his opponent he plays the
move Queen G for attacking a rook now
this move does attack a rook and Karpov
quickly replied with the move rook seat
to d8 now those of you at home this is
one of the most famous chess puzzles of
all time I think but wait to move and
win Gary
successfully has swindled Anatoly Karpov
in this equal position and now will win
the game with style so I encourage you
guys at home to go ahead pause your
video and make an effort to try and find
the solution King Lear remembers this
Karpov missed a tactic that is true that
is true
okay so chat is still waiting on some
delay I'm going to show the answer now
the move of course is Queen takes t7 and
this move simply is crushing of course
you have to recapture this your opponent
just took a rook but now the movie rook
e8 check comes on the board this King is
attacked King age seven and now Bishop
a4 check and these white rooks are are
just far far far far too powerful here I
believe Karpov resigned to the best of
my memory the game could have continued
with something like g6
Herick takes D seven bishops detect they
should pay six Bishop takes and then if
you take this guy back well this is
checkmate so a very very quick win by
Garry Kasparov in this world
championship match this is one of the
more famous games but for the purposes
of this lecture we loved those tactics
and all this is a great way for black
tea to equalize that Anatoly Karpov is
found so while Gary did walk away with
the full point from that position
perhaps in a totally Karpov won the
opening battle meaning the next time we
see this opening perhaps Gary is going
to have to try something a little bit
different like I said these iqp
positions if White has to end up playing
d5 and simplify it more often than not
it's just going to be equal why don't we
jump to game number four for the lecture
there are six games in the World
Championship match that followed this
line I want to hope to get to the mall
and this game actually occurred the next
time Gary had white round 13 of the
match and it went d4 Knight f6 c4 e6
Knight c3 Bishop e4 Knight f3 and now
the move c5 Karpov kind of comes full
circle perhaps realizing that the most
popular move order is actually the best
move order so this is what happened in
game 1 and note that in the pre
yeah in the previous game black Castle
first and then after Bishop g5 played c5
but this allows white this option of
playing III with this Bishop outside the
pawn chain here III is slightly less
less easy you know you don't really want
to box in your bishop like this unless
you have to
so because of that Kasparov repeated his
move from game one g3 and now Karpov did
not go down that same variation that led
him to tragedy in game 1 with 94 rather
first including the move knight c6 and
this is actually a pretty clever
addition now after the move Bishop g4
Bishop g2 rather we do see the move
Knight e4 and what has changed here
while Karpov has done homework is what
has changed here in this annoying Queen
d3 move that brought him some strife in
game 1 is not really going to be
playable here for white it's not losing
by any means but now black does have the
extra option of capturing here on d4 now
after Knight takes d4 you can expect
Knight takes c3 B takes c3 and the move
Knight e5 and now black is really going
to be saving all of his pieces here the
Queen has to keep an eye on the c3 pawn
it so Queen c2 Bishop e7 and this is
just a slightly uncomfortable structure
for for white here and he has not really
gotten much in return for it
so Queen d3 not going to be the best
move here thanks to this nice Knight on
this C 6 squared being able to do things
like jump to e5 so not Queen d3 but
rather Bishop d2 was played in the game
by Kasparov now by far the most common
move here is going to be Knight takes D
to simply taking off this Bishop and
keeping blocks options open
Karpov went for a slightly more concrete
and Bishop takes c3 now of course we've
seen in previous games rather than play
a move Queen takes c3 Kasparov played B
takes c3 and that is actually the case
here as well rather than Bishop takes
Kass profit does go for pawn takes
solidifying the center a little bit more
now castles by black castles by whites
and black continues with the move f5 and
this one feels a little bit shaky to me
I'm not sure Karpov actually had the
best prep here thus far f5 more or less
is the novelty in this variation at
least at the time
at the time f5 I think was was the new
move that Karpov came up with here and
it's pretty intuitive move right you
want to defend this night on the e4
square you want to go after these slight
squares perhaps you can even follow up
by putting a bishop on this diagonal as
well but the fact is whenever you play
the move
whenever you play the move f5 you are
weakening a ton of squares and I think
that's actually the case here Bishop e3
is Kasparov's choice and this is
actually a pawn sacrifice so Knight
takes c3 does come on the board now
Queen d3 C takes d4 is an important
inclusion the Knight takes d4 it's this
Knight again
so Knight comes back to e4 and now the
move c5 is Kasparov's idea and this is a
this is a pretty interesting one I'm not
gonna lie to you guys I I kind of like
what Karpov did in this game and what's
more impressive unless he really had you
know all just all of the prep for
everything I think he found this one
over the board so how do you come up
with an idea like Bishop e3 here well
the point is your opponent has just
played the move f5 f5 is really
weakening some of these central light
squares so what does Kasparov do he
looks for ways to open up the position
while he has these two bishops while he
has an advantage in time a little bit
note that this Bishop on c8 is still
completely undeveloped so the move
Bishop e3 is intended to make the threat
of D takes c5 even and allow this Queen
to come out to d3 and already playing
slightly more normal moves can be a
little bit scary here for example if you
play the move b6 for first of all to
move d5 might come on the board
challenging more of these slight squares
then what Queen d3 might also come on
the board the move D takes c5 with the
point of white's previous move might
come on the board and already you know
white is immediately opening things up
trying to immediately take advantage of
the play so that's what you need to look
for and that's I think how Karpov came
to the realization that Bishop e3 was a
pretty good move here so Knight takes c3
at Queen
364 the night takes 94 c5 as we said now
if you do take this pawn on c5 you are
losing a piece to Knight takes c6
counter-attacking this queen
so this pawn is untouchable the move
Knight takes d4 instead Bishop takes d4
b6 and now after Bishop takes c4 F takes
e4 and Queen takes e4 this is another
position where I think Karpov is just
gonna be slightly worse in this in this
endgame here now Karpov being Karpov did
manage to draw this game but if he
wasn't Karpov I think he might lose this
one just because the white pieces are so
active already and black pieces struggle
a bit Bishop a6 though is a nice move to
attack this e to pawn C takes b6 is
natural a takes b6 and now the move
Queen e5 feels a little bit soft from
from Kasparov it it's kind of just a one
move threat here Queen e7 and Queen f6
are both moves that black was happy to
play anyways
perhaps a little bit better was the
immediate rook F 2 b1 just challenging
these weaknesses on the Queen side
immediately it's going to be a little
bit awkward for black in this endgame I
can't say for certain if it's enough for
some very serious winning attempts but
it is something to play for
Queenie v instead though and after Queen
f6 the Queen just retreats back to h3 or
to III and Karpov and goes for some
simplifications with Queen h6 takes
takes further fracturing this pawn
structure but in return giving the
Queen's off the board and now these
rooks are going to come to very active
squares Bishop c4 a3 b5 cements this
Bishop rook to d1 and now Erick f5
Bishop b2 and rook rook d5 this trick
does get active and as previously stated
and here the players just agreed to a
draw not too much actually to play for
in this endgame but once again Karpov
almost finding himself in a little bit
of trouble here having to deal with the
problems presented by White's bishop
pair so early on is a little bit
intimidating so now let's see with the
final
fifteen minutes how Kasparov changed
changed up how Karpov changed it up in
the latter part of the match those first
few games all happened pretty early on
of course it was a 24 game match so you
know plenty of time to play these things
now this one is round 17 and I think by
round 17 Karpov was down a game I might
be mixing a few things up there I think
he was down either one or two games at
this point in the match and so Karpov is
perhaps feeling a little bit under
pressure here so let's see how he
approached this one d4 Knight f6 c4 e6
Knight c3 Bishop b4 it Knight f3 c5 once
again g3 knight c6 so Karpov going for
the exact same line that we saw in the
previous game now Bishop cheat 294
Bishop d2 takes on c3 takes on c3
castles castles and now the move you
just saw was the move f5 and like I said
f5 actually wasn't my favorite move from
Karpov and it looked like Kasparov ended
up getting a little bit of an initiative
there for a few turns although it did
die quickly after the move Queen e5 a
lot of them simplifying in that previous
game so the pressure was really on
Karpov here to come up with a new move
besides this f5 and that he did with the
move Knight a5 immediately challenging
the Queen side structure here by white
of course it does leave this Knight
feeling slightly more loose on the e4
square but there's no real way for white
to take advantage of this play the move
95 well I'm just going to take this
Bishop it's and what have you really
achieved this is is going to come
through so tonight a 5 immediately
creating pressure now D takes d5 is
Garry Kasparov's reply and this is a bit
of a strange one bye bye Gary these
triple pawns are pretty bad and the
reason they're so bad is once you lose
one which I mean you're always losing
one here the other two are even more
weak note in all those other positions
where Gary ended up in vain
he managed to end up with a pawn on the
D file in Game one it was by you know
the squared queen d3 trade in a later
game it was it will in a later game I
don't think we ever saw a structure like
this but without the pawn on the D file
or the B file these pawns are really
just going to be pretty weak here so
Queen c7 94 by Kasparov and 94 I think
is the move that really gets Karpov a
little bit of an edge in this game the
move Bishop f4 is actually what has been
played these days there is a game from
2006 between a couple 2600
that went with Bishop f4 the game
continued with Queen C 595 Knight takes
e4 and Knight takes or sorry not Knight
takes d7 which i think is a bad move but
rather queen d4 it's the game of the
2600 and after Queen takes d4 C takes d4
White has fixed these pawns a little bit
and Knight takes e5 d takes e5 and I'm
dealing with some awkwardness with this
white with this Knight the move f5 was
in fact played in this game
of course it's less suspect here because
the Queen's are already off the board
and the skin continued with takes f6 and
takes f6 and here you know why it has a
maybe a slight pull in these types of
end games Bishop d6 was played at rook
f7 the move Knight EA it's going to come
and I move like d5 it wasn't enough for
white to win in this case so the move
Bishop f4 though is is really going to
be the best way for white to play here
after Knight d4 really the only thing
white had going for him in this position
was the fact that he had the bishop pair
which is why Bishop f4 is the best move
now Knight takes D 2 and Karpov has
absolutely nothing to worry about
Queen takes D to Knight see for Queen up
to g5 protects this pawn for a moment
but f6 Queen f4 95 Knight back to b3
work over to b8 stepping off with the
long diagonal and you know Kasparov
isn't much worse if he is worse at all
but there's certainly nothing to play
for here he's just going to be
babysitting these pawns Queen d4 b6 and
Karpov is slightly more comfortably
solving the problem with the
this game f4 from Karpov does shake
loose this night but the f7 square isn't
so bad
rook over to d1 now rook d8 c4 and black
finishes development finally with Bishop
e7 we see takes takes takes takes c5 c6
still pressuring this pawn a bit Rick a
c1 and now the freeing moved d5 by
Karpov really throws away any ideas of
winning the game that white may have
still had with pressure on the D file C
takes D six rook takes D six Queen e3
takes takes g6 takes takes takes oh
sorry not takes button rather Queen c5
and here the players agreed to a draw so
this I think is the first time when
Karpov really got the better of Kasparov
in this opening but you know perhaps
instead of the move Knight d4 if the
move Bishop f4 had been played
Kasparov would have had a little bit of
a better chance so this is the type of
one off that you'll see in these World
Championship matches the players will
play something and if you know Gary had
found you know perhaps the absolute best
continuation he has like a slight pull
in an endgame but this being totally new
to him probably he's not going to find
it all and so Karpov gets an easy draw
in round 17 now finally it with the last
10 minutes
one more game I wanted to look at for
you guys we were going at breakneck
speed here this of course is game 19 in
the match now game 19 of 24 and this is
the game that really pushed Kasparov
over the edge I think with this win here
Kasparov I think this is the moment when
he went up two games forgive me I don't
remember the score round by round but
this was a critical one late in the
match for Kasparov and let's see how he
did it
bringing out this Knight f3 nimza weapon
one more time so the move d4 Knight f6
once again for the 6th time we reached
the nimzo-indian now Knight f3 and back
to his old ways the move Knight e4
perhaps not totally back to his old ways
but this same night maneuver the
difference here of course is the move c5
has not been included so once again it
is Karpov coming up with new ideas here
now the move Queen c2 is the move that
was played in the game and I think it is
just going to be the best move here
thanks to the non inclusion of c5 white
has to be slightly less worried about
the pressure on d4 which is why he's
more comfortable moving the Queen away
from the defense of this pawn hitting
this Knight now black has to make a
decision and so black plays the move f5
even earlier in this case now the move
g3 comes on the board this is just going
to be the best Square for the bishop and
now knight c6 by Karpov is a bit of a
bit of a weird one in my database the
only time this has ever been played is
this time this has not been repeated by
anybody to my to my knowledge anybody
who's anybody at least I'm sure if you
have the mega database maybe you'll
you'll find a game or two but this one
is is rather uncomfortable actually for
black you put this knight on c6 and I
just don't fully understand why why we
need to do this the night later comes
out to a5 and this was most likely
Karpov was point but but why are we
doing this to ourselves why are we
limiting our chances to play the move c5
which is really a key break here for
black remember that one game when Karpov
did nothing in the center never played
the move c5 and ended up suffering for
quite a bit so 96 not my favorite move
of all time it just doesn't really make
sense to me Bishop g2 now castles
castles Bishop takes c3 B takes c3 goes
for this structure again now the move
Knight a5 and I'll let you guys at home
try and find Garry Kasparov's reply to
this move nope that's I may have given
you a hint that one particularly move
one particular move is very much an
important move for black here and with
this next move Gary is preventing it
forever
Kasparov led by one point going into
this game yes so Kasparov was up one
game this is around nineteen of twenty
four so you know not desperate times yet
for Karpov but certainly feeling in the
pressure of being down a game against
the Challenger with just five games left
to go
okay Great Wolf has finally returned
from lunch he apologizes for being late
to class I will forgive him on this
occasion
but a tardy will be noted on your report
card okay
chess is fun says the move Bishop a3
well hold on chess is fun your pawns
attacked
don't lose your pawn so in previous
games we had seen Gary play move like
Queen d3 to try and hold everything
together
Queen d3 in this case doesn't actually
make the most sense you're walking right
into the move b6 when Bishop a6 is going
to put you in a rather uncomfortable pin
so the move that Gary actually came up
with here as Nikolas now is saying is
the move c5 you prevent black from
playing c5 himself you increase your
space and you actually kind of fix your
pawn structure in a weird way
now Anatoly directly challenges this
pawn on c5 it can't really just be
allowed to stand there we need to
develop this bishop somehow so we need
to move one of these pawns so he chose
the move d6 to challenge the pawn and
Gary comes up with a really nice move
here to continue increasing his activity
a little bit rather than just play some
move like rook d1 like rugby one like C
takes D six he plays the move C 4 and I
like this move quite a bit it's
challenging black to take on c5 when
afterwards we're going to have first of
all in e5 square look out for that one
maybe we shouldn't have put our pawn on
f5 but yeah we're gonna have 85 square
for the knight that's going to be
difficult to drive it away from we're
also going to have pressure along this
diagonal now so Gary really tempting
Karpov to go for a little bit more and
perhaps this temptation is is going to
be enough against some players being
down a game towards the end of the match
but Karpov the professional just plays
b6 instead challenging this pawn more
directly with the beep on and now
Kasparov plays a slightly
counterintuitive move at first glance
but it is with good reason it's the move
Bishop d2 now in previous games we had
seen that night 62 was a great
equalizing ID
by Karpov getting rid of the bishop pair
in this case though after it is played
and we have night takes D - now we are
gaining a a really critical tempo on
this rook on a8
if this rook comes to b8 well now we'll
simplify it with C takes D six and
perhaps C takes D six and after the move
Knight b3 this Knight is it's just a
little bit awkward you can take on b3
but now you're a pawn is slightly weak
you can come back to b7 I suppose but
you don't want to be on p7 almost as bad
as g7 and lastly you can just leave it
here on a5 but of course not the most
comfortable structure now for for black
with these double date pawns
so rather than Rick b8 Karpov goes for
the move
d5 here trying to block out this Bishop
on the light squares and this is a
hugely combative move of course the most
natural move is the move that was played
in the game C takes d5 you get rid of
your doubled C pawn you weaken the light
squares further it makes total sense
so E takes d5 and now III by Kasparov is
just solidifying the structure and it's
clear to see that that white is just
much better in this position from the
opening it's moved 15 now both sides
have more or less gotten developed after
blacks next move and Bishop e6 but
what's going on in the position well
white has this beautiful pawn chain of
f2 to c5 he has a beautiful bishop on g2
all of the white pawn the black pawns
rather are locked on light squares on
squares that are easily targetable by
the white pieces and to boot
you know it's white to move so going to
be a really nice position here for
Kasparov and this is why I just don't
like these f5 ideas that Karpov was
trying in all of these games no I think
in every game where Karpov played f5 he
just ended up worse since I really
really combative move that risks
quite a lot and if there's one lesson to
be learned from all of these games I
think it's that like maybe slow down on
these f5 ideas ok men like they're not
they're not great not great
all right storms getting a tardy on his
fur report card - oh my gosh oh my gosh
these hooligans students hooligan
students ok Queen c3 played in the game
rook f7 Rick FC one rook b8 I'm gonna
play through these moves rather quickly
as we are beyond the opening and I do
want to do a brief recap a4 by Kasparov
is nice to just keep this pawn right
back there on b6 and Bishop f7 now by
Karpov Bishop f1 challenging some more
light squares h6 and now the rear out of
the bishop is complete - an even better
square on d3 Queen d7 defends this guy
Queen c2 attacks this guy which should
be six defends this guy it should be
five attacks this guy going back to d8
and now there's a little bit of
maneuvering rook d1 I don't fully
understand but I don't need to
understand it g5 Knight f3 heading to e5
rook g7 95 as stated note that this F
pawn cannot come to f6 to drive this
night away so sad F for now Bishop back
to f1 for just a little bit of Defense
Queen f6 Bishop g2 rook over to d8 and
now the movie for is nice by a cat's
brow this is really the the move that's
that's breaking through for him here you
play it for you break down kind of the
last defenders of the blacks light
squares and of blacks light squares and
the rest is kind of just history here D
takes e4 Bishop takes e4 rookie 7 Queen
c3 Bishop up to d5 trying to blockade on
this d5 square but just tricky one
and after a few more moves in a g4 I
mean f7 thanks takes takes takes rook e1
rook D 895 daring black to take this guy
when you are in an unfortunate pen Queen
f6 C takes b6 Queen takes and now after
Roe takes d4 Knight f3 Knight be three
rook be one Queen f6 take c7
car pop went ahead and resigned the skin
of course I blew through the rest of
this game hopefully you all agree with
me that after the opening white is just
significantly better but what keV we
learned about the three Knights
variation as it's called of the
nimzo-indian with this move Knight f3
well Black has a lot of different ways
to respond and it really just comes down
to the concrete positions when we saw in
Game one
Karpov got in quite a bit of trouble
here after taking this pawn on b2 and
stepping to the wrong Square allowing
white to consolidate with these ponds
and black in this game had a lot of
trouble in developing this Bishop a lot
of trouble with this pawn on c5 later on
Karpov tried to do nothing tried not to
play c5 not do anything and he ended up
in a cramped position just slightly
worse and eventually we had this one
game game 11 that Karpov lost where
Karpov equalized fairly standard lee
going for more iqp
standard positions so these are just
various different methods of playing
against the three nights that Karpov and
Kasparov explored pretty thoroughly in
the match and so this is why I highly
recommend looking at World Championship
matches for the latest and greatest
opening theory they really explore these
variations very very deeply and you can
learn a lot about the various ideas
hopefully you enjoyed this edition of
chess openings explained as well if
you're watching live be sure to head
over to the twitch channel we're going
to have an hour of tactics time with
yours truly if you're watching the video
version thank you very much for joining
me my name is Caleb Denby and I will see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you